Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof?
Good day, Walter.
Good day, Martin. Are you well?
Yes, I have a
frog in the throat, but uh
we'll see if he behaves himself. We'll
get him out of the
So, we're going to
talk about
the councils
after the Reformation.
Because there was some confusion and we
didn't clarify
the difference between the Council of
Trent, the
Vatican Council 1 and Vatican Council 2,
and maybe we
We messed it up a little bit. So, let's
fix it.
Correct.
So, let's open with a word of prayer.
Thank you.
Our heavenly Father, thank you so much
for giving us the opportunity to study
your word, to study history, and to put
it all into perspective. We ask that you
bless us and enlighten our minds and
help us through this lecture. In Jesus'
name, amen. Amen.
You see, Martin,
we are so
involved in in exactly what is happening
and how it all fits together
that we have to be very careful to get
our his- historicity
uh correctly stated.
So, we are going to talk now about
understanding Pope Francis, the
post-reformation councils
to just show that there were
various councils and some decrees
between councils
Mhm. Very important.
and uh how they affect what is
happening.
Now, what is of course important in all
of this is what is the outcome.
What were the decrees?
What were the statements? What is the
end result of all of this?
And uh we will be looking at that. But,
just to set the record straight,
let's go to a little bit of history
and let's see how we can put the
progression
in the correct sequence. Yes.
But, let's start off with a statement
from the Spirit of Prophecy.
This comes from The Great Controversy,
page 193.
Fearlessly did Luther defend the gospel
from the attacks which came from every
The word of God proved itself a weapon
mighty in every conflict.
With the word, he warred against the
usurped authority of the Pope
and the rationalistic philosophy of the
schoolmen.
While he stood firm as a rock against
the fanaticism that sought to ally
itself with the Reformation.
Now, Martin, this is a very interesting
statement. There are three things that
are highlighted here.
And
he used the word
which was mighty in the conflict to do
these three things.
Number one,
he used the word to war against the
usurped authority of the Pope.
Do we still have to do that today? Yes.
We have to use the word to war against
the usurped authority of the Pope.
Lest the whole world be swallowed up
in falsities. Correct.
And this is one of the reasons why we
are so adamant in bringing about or
bringing out these series. Yes, to make
people aware. Yes.
It's not in harmony with the Bible, the
way that they usurped authority.
Correct. And sweet words and gentle
tones
steeped in falsehood, contrary to the
scripture
are a most dangerous potion.
So, we must use the word to war against
usurped authority of the Pope.
The second thing he warred again was the
rationalistic philosophy of the
schoolmen.
Now, that's a very interesting statement
because
you know, Christ battled with the
scribes and the Pharisees. Yes. And the
schoolmen Yes. were very adamant about
what is written
that was never written in the way that
they thought it was written or that it
meant something else than what they said
it meant.
Correct.
And uh we have the same thing today,
dynamic equivalence, which is
maybe dynamic, but never equivalent.
And then, the third thing
is he stood firm as a rock against the
fanaticism
that sought to ally itself with the
Reformation.
Now, fanaticism in those days was
something else
to what it is today.
Fanaticism then referred to these
emotional experiences
that we discussed in our last What's Up
that tended to disrupt the order of the
church.
Where
uh the idea was that the spirit is going
to guide and the word is not going to be
the norm. So, whatever the spirit
dictates. And we saw that out of Vatican
it became very prominent that the spirit
was going to be the norm and not the
word, right?
Yes.
But now, you have to try and appease
Protestantism if you want to bring
Protestantism into the fold, right?
So, you package it in these beautiful
words and this is what we were
discussing. Looking at the deception.
So, those three things, war against the
usurped authority of the Pope
war against the rationalistic philosophy
of the schoolmen
all of these Greek philosophies that
have been incorporated which are
contrary to the scripture
and then against this
free-for-all
spirit so-called driven phenomenon
that sets aside the law of God and the
word of God for the experience.
Yes.
Each of these opposing elements was in
its own way setting aside the Holy
Scriptures.
You see that?
Each one of them attacks God's word.
Yes. And this is what we have to do.
This is our job.
Exactly. And it And they don't make they
don't make any bones about it. No. The
reformers never made any bones about it.
That was their job. And even the
Catholic system also don't make any
bones about their stance on what the
scriptures' authority is. They say that
they are above it.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Each of these opposing elements was in
its own way setting aside the Holy
Scriptures, exalting human wisdom as the
source of religious truth and knowledge.
Rationalism idolizes reason.
Now, Martin, didn't we discuss reason?
Yes.
And the writings of the Jesuit Gula who
said that reason must inform your faith.
Yes.
Whereas the Protestant version would be,
in my opinion, your faith
must determine your reason.
Exactly.
So, it idolizes reason and makes this
the criterion for religion. Romanism,
claiming for her sovereign pontiff an
inspiration descended in unbroken line
from the apostles
and unchangeable throughout all time,
gives ample opportunity for every
species of extravagance and corruption
to be concealed under the sanctity of
the apostolic commission.
This is interesting.
So, this unbroken line that they refer
to from Peter to the present Pope gives
them the authority to make null and void
even the precepts of Christ.
Well, let's say put it their supposed
unbroken line of authority that they
But, they claim it to themselves. They
Like we've seen
it doesn't even hold
water in the history. Correct.
The inspiration claimed by Muntzer
Now, Muntzer was
one of the
people that brought fanaticism into the
Protestant Church. He was
largely responsible for the peasant
revolt as well.
And his associates proceeded from no
higher source than the vagaries of the
imagination.
And its influence was subversive of all
authority, human or divine.
Now, doesn't the Jesuit order teach that
the imagination is the one that will
control the outcome?
Yes, because it comes from the exercises
of Loyola. Correct.
Imagination.
True Christianity receives the word of
God as the great treasure house of
inspired truth and the test of all
inspiration.
That is the basis of the battle that is
raging in the world today.
This is the basis of the battle that has
been raging from the time of Adam.
Correct. If we do not identify these
three features,
then we will be swept away in a current
that will lead us over the precipice to
destruction.
Correct.
So, that's why we have to speak about
all of this. Correct. Otherwise, we are
not protesting. Yes.
And what are we protesting against?
Against the obliteration of scripture
by means of philosophy and fanaticism in
the old sense of the word.
Yes, and if you don't illuminate all of
this
to people,
then you will be swept in by even your
own denomination that's not Catholic
because you won't realize that they're
actually teaching a Catholic doctrine.
Correct. Let us just clarify the
councils to make it absolutely clear and
historically correct.
So, the first council to be held after
the Reformation
was the Council of Trent.
The Council of Trent was held between
and
1563.
It was held in a number of sessions.
Mhm.
And there were sometimes long periods in
between sessions.
Uh it was of course accepted by the
Catholic Church. The previous council
had been the fifth council of the latter
in 1512 to 1517. That was prior
to the Reformation.
The next council after the Council of
Trent was the First Vatican Council,
which was held more than 300 years
later. Mhm.
1869 to 1870.
Now, the Council of Trent was convoked
by Paul the third,
Julius the third, who was not Pope at
that stage. He was a co-president and he
was a cardinal at that stage.
And Pius the fourth.
Attendance about 255 during the final
session.
And the topics were Protestantism
and the counter-reformation.
This is where the great debate took
place
about the legality of Protestantism,
whether it was a movement or whether it
was a protest
or whether it was a rebellion. Mhm.
And at the Council of Trent, they
decided that it was a rebellion
because the Protestants didn't adhere to
sola scriptura
because they accepted Sunday, which was
based on the tradition of the church.
And that's what the Archbishop of Reggio
said in that council. And then finally,
as a consequence of that statement, the
Reformation was condemned Okay. as being
a rebellion. Correct.
And all the doctrine, particularly sola
scriptura, justification by faith alone,
sola Christus, that works had nothing to
do with your salvation, those were
rejected by the Council of Trent.
They accepted 17 dogmatic decrees
covering the then disputed aspects of
Catholic religion. So, in other words,
they confirmed
the Catholic position, condemned
the Reformation position.
That happened at the Council of Trent.
Now, how important was the Council of
Trent? Now, when we look at uh
Pope Francis,
Pope Francis makes many, many statements
which appear to be contrary to the
Council of Trent.
And many conservative Catholics are
highly upset because of this.
But we need to understand the motive and
the game.
The Vatican II Council
was
there to bring the separated
children back into the fold of the Roman
Catholic Church.
And therefore, there had to be a
compromise
which did not compromise the Catholic
position, but appeared to compromise it.
So, we have to look very carefully at
wording, for example.
And here is a very interesting clip from
Bishop Schneider
who responded to a question on the
errors of Luther
and the comments of the Pope
which seemed to say that Luther had been
correct, which would contradict the
Council of Trent, right?
And this interplay is very important.
So, let's just listen to it and then
we'll discuss it.
He has a rather heavy German accent, but
I'm sure people will understand.
Your Your Excellency, thank you for
being here today. My question is, since
the discussion is about heresy, one
heretic who comes to mind is Martin
Luther, whose 500th anniversary of the
Reformation uh the Pope will be
commemorating um
in the very soon very shortly.
Uh on an airplane interview, the Pope
recently said that Martin Luther who did
not err on the issue of justification.
What is your response to the Lutheran
heresy
and uh on the issue of justification and
the upcoming ecumenical events and how
do traditional Catholics respond to
uh the reports that are coming out?
They have already had an infallible
response
to the errors of Martin Luther.
The Council of Trent.
The definition of the Council of Trent
about the errors of Luther, I repeat,
are infallible
ex cathedra.
And the comments of the Pope in the
plane
are not ex cathedra.
Well, Martin, that was very clear,
wasn't it?
Yes.
So, what he's saying is
the comments of the Pope
were not ex cathedra. Yes.
Meaning? They were not infallible. Mhm.
Whereas the Council of Trent, those
statements were
infallible
ex cathedra. They cannot be changed
ever.
That's a very important clue.
In other words, you can say many things
and you know that the Jesuits have a
saying that you can lie if it favors
Mother Church.
Yes, it is. To further the If the end
justifies the means.
The end must justify the means. So, this
is this is how they operate.
And the fact that they can't change
their laws
also is seen
in the beast in Revelation
that is a
combination of all the beasts, all four
beasts in Daniel. Correct.
And the one is
the Medo-Persians. Correct.
And their laws were unchangeable.
Correct. They couldn't change it. Yeah.
So, the the question of papal
infallibility
that he mentioned
was a given.
And
they called
themselves ultramontanists.
The man on the other side of the
mountain.
Yeah. The Protestants used to use it as
a term of mockery.
But the papacy changed turned it into a
term of endearment.
The man other side the mountain, he was
infallible. Yes. But it hadn't been
proclaimed as a dogma.
Now, that's very interesting.
So, in order to substantiate
that the decrees throughout the ages
that were based on tradition were
unchangeable,
they had to be infallible. Correct. So,
that happened at the next council, which
was the First Vatican Council. So, let's
look at this cuz it's very important
that we understand how this
beast of Revelation chapter 13
with all its components,
with the lion component of Babylon in
it, with the leopard component of Greece
in it, with a bear component of the
Medo-Persians in it, that it complies to
all of those criteria.
So, if we go to the First Vatican
Council,
apparently this council was interrupted
because of war.
And the Second Vatican Council is, in
fact, a continuation
of a basically uncompleted First Vatican
Council.
But, it nevertheless has a very
important historic application, because
it took place
to 1870.
Again, it was the Catholic Church that
called it. The previous council had been
the Council of Trent.
The next council after it would be the
Second Vatican Council from 1962 to
1965.
And the First Vatican Council was
convoked by Pope Pius the Ninth, and he
was the president. And there were 744
attendants. Now, the topics are
interesting. Rationalism,
liberalism,
materialism,
inspiration of scripture,
papal infallibility.
And the documents are these that came
out of it. A Dei Filius and Pastor
Aeternus.
Now,
what is fascinating about this council
is that the doctrine of papal
infallibility was made a dogma.
Unchangeable.
And that referred to all the previous
councils as well, as we heard from
Bishop Schneider.
It was ex cathedra
infallible.
Can never be changed.
If Protestantism
would understand that,
they would never be part of an
ecumenical council.
Correct.
Never. So, it's always if they if it
doesn't look like it, look deeper. Look
deeper.
Now, this pope, Pope Pius the Ninth,
the First Vatican Council, Latin
Concilium Vaticanum Primum, was convoked
by Pope Pius the Ninth on the 29th of
June, 1868,
after a period of planning and
preparation that began on the 6th of
December, 1864.
Now, remember the Second Vatican Council
was also announced in 1959
already, but only took place in '62.
So, there was also a period of
preparation and planning.
Now, what is interesting about this
particular pope that called the First
Vatican Council
is that in 1854,
that is before the council,
he had defined as dogma the Immaculate
Conception of Mary, the mother of Jesus.
Now, in view of Vatican II, this dogma
also became infallible.
Because he
proclaimed it.
Right.
So, we need to look at this Immaculate
Conception of Mary. It's a very
important dogma.
And how does it fit into the time that
we are living in? Does it belong,
Martin,
to a previous era of the Roman Catholic
Church? Nothing of the Roman Catholic
Church belongs to a previous era,
because they're infallible. So,
everything comes through and it will
never change.
It cannot change.
So, in the spirit of prophecy, we have
that statement that she is like the
chameleon.
Maybe I must just clarify. According to
them, they're infallible. Yes.
But, this chameleon, it takes on all
colors and blends into the background.
But, blended or not, it's still a
chameleon.
Perfect.
So, this just sets the record straight
on the councils.
Now, let's just go to Catholic News
Agency, the Immaculate Conception.
Because so many people believe that this
refers to Jesus being immaculate. But,
of course, it doesn't.
It refers to Mary being immaculate. And
it's very important that we understand
these issues.
And this is infallible.
So, in 1854, Pope Pius, this comes from
the Catholic News Agency,
solemn declaration
Inneffabilis Deus clarifies with
finality the long-held belief of the
church that Mary was conceived free from
original sin.
Well, there are a number of errors in
that statement already, because we don't
inherit original sin.
Because according to the scripture,
sin cannot be referred transferred
from one to another.
You will have to stand for your own sin.
So, the sins of the fathers, according
to the scripture, cannot be transferred
to the children and vice versa.
But, Catholics claim that we inherit
original sin. We inherit the sin. We
don't inherit the sin. We inherit the
fallen nature as a consequence of the
sin.
The propensity to sin. Correct.
Otherwise, it would be unfair of God.
So, in proclaiming the Immaculate
Conception of Mary as a dogma of the
church, the pope expressed precisely and
clearly that Mary was conceived free
from the stain of original sin. She was
immaculate.
Martin, let's just stop there.
What is our weapon? The Bible, right?
Yes, the sword.
Without the shedding of blood, there is
no forgiveness of sins.
The Bible is absolutely clear
that through the blood of the lamb, we
are saved.
It is the sacrifice of Christ that saves
us from our sins. Right?
Correct.
Now, it's interesting that in the
Catholic mass, there is a bloodless
sacrifice.
These are all little hints as to how you
remove Jesus out of the equation.
Not only that,
if you are saved only through the blood
of the lamb,
then can God declare you immaculate
without it? No.
No.
What is the condition of being declared
perfect? We've discussed this many times
on WhatsApp.
You have to have the righteousness of
Christ covering you. Uh-huh.
And that implies that you have to
forsake your sins.
You have to
repent. Yes.
And after you have repented,
then Christ will forgive your sins.
Because of your repentance, you come to
Christ,
and your sins are forgiven and washed
away, and he covers you with his
righteousness.
Right?
Yes.
Now, if Mary was immaculate without that
process, and the reason they say it is
so,
is so that Jesus could be born
immaculate,
without sin.
In a sense, they're actually saying his
immaculate nature,
his sinless nature, comes from Mary.
Definitely.
Now, is my question, Martin.
It's been my question from the
beginning,
seeing that I come from a Catholic
background.
If God, through his omnipotence,
could
circumvent his own rules, the wages of
sin is death,
and declare her immaculate
without the blood,
then couldn't he have done it for you?
Yes. Then what was the point of the
cross?
There would have been no point. The
Immaculate Conception of Mary negates
the necessity of the cross.
Because God, by decree, could declare
everyone immaculate
if he so wished.
So, let's continue. The Catechism of the
Catholic Church says of the Immaculate
Conception of Mary,
"The splendor of an entirely unique
holiness,
by which Mary is enriched from the first
instant of her conception,
comes wholly from Christ. She is
redeemed in a more exalted fashion by
reason of the merits of her son.
The Father blessed Mary more than any
other created person.
In Christ with every spiritual blessing
in the heavenly places, and chose her in
Christ before the foundation of the
world to be holy and blameless before
him in love.
The fathers of the Eastern tradition
called the Mother of God the all holy,
Panagia,
and celebrate her as free from any stain
of sin,
as though fashioned by the Holy Spirit
and formed as a new creature by the
grace of God, Mary remained free of
every personal sin for her whole life
long.
Now, Martin, if she is free from all
sin,
then she could have been the savior.
Does she need a redeemer?
No.
She doesn't need a redeemer. But the
Bible says she was born under the law.
Mhm.
Which means that she was born under the
condemnation of the law. She was like
one of us.
Isn't that correct?
Definitely.
So, this dogma bypasses the plan of
salvation.
Mhm.
And frees us from the blood of the lamb.
Correct. And you see the problem is if
you read through this,
it's almost like sugarcoated. So, it
sounds good, like we said earlier, if it
looks good, look deeper. And that's why
you at the way you explained it just
now.
This This is such a travesty of justice,
it's unbelievable.
And that is why, if you study further,
you will understand why the Catholic
view of the atonement
is that Christ never died for you.
Correct. It wasn't the blood. It was the
good works.
So, this is a very serious issue.
And Protestants need to understand this.
Yes. And remember that it's infallible.
So, some years ago,
Time magazine brought out this
uh cover here. Hail Mary, Catholics have
long revered her,
but now Protestants are finding their
own reasons to celebrate the mother of
Jesus.
Have they been successful in their
endeavor
to push this doctrine down the throats
of Protestantism? Definitely, yes.
Here is an an article from the National
Catholic Reporter,
and it says about Pope
John Paul the Second,
the Pope may declare Mary co-redemptrix.
Special to the National Catholic
Reporter, at 77 and in uneven health,
John Paul the Second invests virtually
every allocution with some mention of
his advancing years and of his devotion
to Mary, the mother of Jesus. Before he
dies, he may decide to use his charism
of infallibility
to elevate Mary's crown another tier.
So, he might declare a
co-redemptrix. Now, it never happened.
Mhm. It never happened. And the reason
why I believe it never happened is
because this would be a particular nail
in the coffin of the ecumenical
movement.
Because Protestants would
then they would
And now, that's a very Do that again,
Martin.
What did you do? Protestants would
Uh-uh, no. They got uh
uh
My question is, why did they go along
with this nonsense?
Mhm? Exactly. Why did they go along with
what has happened so far? Yes.
And so, he never ever went so far as to
proclaim her co-redemptrix. There's an
article in the magazine where they say
co-redemptrix, mediatrix of all graces.
Mhm.
So, that makes her a co-redeemer and
makes her a
co-mediator.
Now, that's fascinating.
But the point is,
he never went that far.
Never used his so-called papal
infallibility.
But
but
the essence of what he said remained
exactly the same.
And we need to look at that, right?
Correct. So, we will look at that.
Here's a little booklet that I have.
It's a copy, so it's not the original.
And we will we will study it to some
extent.
Now, that brings us then, Martin, to the
Second Vatican Council. And Pope John
Paul the Second was a post-Vatican
II
Pope.
So, let's look at the Second Vatican
Council and get the dates right. It was
from the 11th of October, 1962 to the
8th of December, 1965.
Again, it was the Catholic Church. The
previous council had been
the First Vatican Council.
That had declared the Pope infallible.
And the same Pope also declared that
Mary
was immaculate.
Correct.
The Second Vatican Council was uh
convoked by Pope John the 23rd.
He was also the president, but he died
during the council, and Pope Paul the
Sixth was the one that completed the
council.
Uh there were 2,625
attendees. The topics complete
unfinished task of Vatican I.
And the ecumenical outreach to address
the needs of a modern world.
And as we discussed in our previous one,
this is where Pope Paul the Sixth opted
for man
Mhm.
as the center Yes. and not God.
Correct. So, man
was to have his
kingdom here on Earth. Yes.
Which is, of course, contrary to what
Christ says about his kingdom. Yes, we
also saw that uh
God has to
adapt to the times and not the times to
God. Correct.
And there were a number of writings that
came out of it. We can see a whole host
of them over here.
Uh that came out of the Second Vatican
Council. And we are talking about Pope
Francis as a Second Vatican
Council Pope. Correct.
Now, Martin, another important point
that we mustn't miss is just prior
to the Second Vatican Council,
Pope Pius the 12th in 1950,
that's 12 years before Vatican II,
invoked papal infallibility to define
the doctrine of the Assumption of the
Blessed Virgin in his apostolic
constitution
Munificentissimus
Deus.
Now, that's another interesting
progression Mhm.
infallibly, right?
And again, they state quite clearly
there that he invoked his papal
infallibility
so that Mary never died and went to
heaven. Now, logically, Martin,
if she had no sin,
and the wages of sin is death,
then death doesn't apply to her, right?
Correct.
So, she went to heaven.
So, the proclamation read, "We proclaim
and define it to be a dogma revealed by
God that the immaculate mother of God,
Mary ever virgin, when the course of her
earthly life was finished, was taken up
bodily and soul into the glory of
heaven."
Now, Martin, what should this do to
Protestants?
Let you run.
It should
It should let you run.
I always find it fascinating
that if you go to the Middle East,
then there are a number of graves of
Mary, depending whether you go to the
Orthodox sites or whether you go to the
Catholic sites. Now, what are the Why
are there graves of Mary if she's never
was in one, right?
It just doesn't make any sense. The
whole
dogma is so ridiculous.
But then, the important point that I
want to bring out here
is why
is it even possible?
Why is it even possible
for Protestants to accept
Yeah. that someone like Mary or any of
the other saints
can play an important role
on the other side of this physical
realm?
Because they have neglected an important
point of the Reformation.
Mhm.
Martin Luther was absolutely clear
that the dead sleep. sleep. Correct.
And that they will only wake up when?
At the resurrection, at the second
coming.
At the second coming.
And it will only be the righteous that's
being resurrected at the second coming.
Correct. So, Martin Luther was very
clear on the doctrine of soul sleep.
And so were were the other reformers in
England. They were very, very clear.
But for some reason,
this doctrine, which is so clear in the
Bible when you study it um
was not included in their catechisms.
And the old papal error of immortality
of the soul
was incorporated. So, that opens the
way, of course, for accepting any of
this nonsense
that you can invoke the aid of either
Mary or any of the saints.
Correct.
So, now we can see a progression in time
historically of how these dogmas came
about.
So, if we go to the Vatican webpage to
ask them, please, to define the dogma of
the assumption for us,
then it reads as follows. It is in our
own age that the privilege of the bodily
assumption into heaven of Mary, the
Virgin Mother of God,
has certainly shone forth more clearly.
That privilege has shone forth in new
radiance since our predecessor of
immortal memory,
Pius the IX, solemnly proclaimed the
dogma of the loving Mother of God's
immaculate conception.
According to the general rule, God does
not will to grant to the just the full
effect of the victory over death
until the end of time has come.
And so it is that bodies of even the
just are corrupted after death, and only
in the last day will they be joined each
to his own glorious soul.
Now, let's just stop there.
Mhm.
That is totally unbiblical.
Correct.
Because if you go back to the book of
Genesis, then it tells you quite clearly
that God took the dust of the ground. He
breathed into him the breath of life,
and man became a living soul.
Yes.
And that living soul is the whole
entity, and Martin Luther accepted it as
such.
These people separate them into two
entities
to get away with the corruption of the
physical so that they can maintain that
the non-physical remains alive. Correct.
So, they continue then, "Now, God has
willed that the Blessed Mary should be
exempted from this general rule.
She, by an entirely unique privilege,
completely overcame sin by her
immaculate conception.
No need for redemption, Martin.
And as a result, she was not subject to
the law of remaining in corruption of
the grave.
And she did not have to wait until the
end of time for the redemption of her
body.
Martin, I think they are confused when
they say that this is unique, one of a
kind.
Correct. Because isn't Moses in heaven?
And he was resurrected. But what about
Elijah and Enoch?
Yeah, they were the ones there without
death. Without seeing death. Now, we've
discussed that in previous ones.
had a bit of a
a word problem there between Elisha and
Elijah.
So, Martin, sometimes we make mistakes,
right?
It said Elisha, and we read Elijah, and
sometimes we said Elijah, and sometimes
we we were confused, Martin. I think we
need more sleep or something like that.
Yeah, we sorry. I I'm sure it did come
through what we actually meant. Yes. All
right. But let's not make excuses for
our fallibility.
But anyway, this is a very fascinating
very fascinating dogma. And this one
comes in there just before the Second
Vatican Council.
I mean, Protestants should be so
alarmed.
But they're not.
And after the Second Vatican Council,
there they go.
No problem.
Now, there's a little booklet written by
Kevin McNamara. He's the Bishop of
Kerry.
And it's called Mary, the Mother of God.
And it was published in 1982 by the
Catholic Truth Society in London.
And the subject is Mary, Mother of Jesus
Christ, the theology and the theology of
the Catholic view of of this. Now, the
one who actually defined it
or tried to make it acceptable
to the Protestant world was Pope John
Paul the Second. And this little booklet
by the Bishop of Kerry is to show how
John Paul the Second
presented the data to the Protestant
world so that they could swallow it Yes.
in tasty little morsels.
But of course, he cannot undo any
previous infallible dogma. So, he has to
sail through the quagmire.
Like a
serpent.
Like a serpent, and try to present it as
though it were biblical.
And here's the one where they said
that he would probably
proclaim her as co-redemptrix.
But after Vatican II, that would be
uh
a little bone in the tasty fishy morsel
that might get stuck in the throat of
some. So, they didn't go that far.
But I have the little book here.
And it would perhaps be useful if we
read some of the things that are written
in here because they're all all based on
his speeches
and on his writings.
So, now
Mary, the Mother of God, it starts off
with that statement. Mary, the Mother of
God.
Uh is there a problem with that?
Yes.
I would say there's a problem with that.
You can say Mary, the Mother of Jesus,
right?
Correct.
Now, the fact of the matter is Jesus is
also God, right?
Mhm. Yes. So, was she the Mother of God,
or was she the Mother of
the physical manifestation of God?
Physical manifestation of Jesus. Yes.
Who was God, but So, God obviously
preceded her. Mhm. So, you know, these
are all interesting nuances. So, I'm not
going to go through the whole book, but
there are some important points here.
So,
there's a little uh section here called
Marian doctrine before Vatican II.
And he writes here, "In this period, the
role of Mary was keenly studied, and
devotion to her was fervently practiced
throughout the church."
I mean, that's a historic fact, right?
However, the person of Mary was not
always placed in her full and proper
context.
There was a tendency to extol her
privileges without relating them
sufficiently
to her overall place in God's plan of
redemption.
While the intention was to honor Mary as
much as possible, the effect at times
was to make her appear remote from real
life.
Her glories were highlighted to such an
extent that her personal pilgrimage of
faith tended to fade into the
background.
And because of the brilliant light
surrounding Mary as queen,
the humble Virgin of Nazareth was
sometimes in danger
of being lost to view.
See, the problem was the veneration that
she received, which put off the
Protestants.
Correct.
So, they had to bring her
back to earth a little bit to make her
more acceptable without losing the
attributes because there are some
infallible document dogmas here, right?
Mhm.
She's immaculate.
Unchangeable. Yes. Unchangeable.
She didn't see death. She went straight
to heaven. Does it say so in the
scripture?
No. So, who who informed us of this?
Fortunately, we have a pope, right?
I don't know if it's so fortunate.
Anyway, let's continue.
Mary's wonderful privileges, the great
things done to her by God, are certainly
stressed
and lovingly contemplated, but they are
always linked by the Pope to Mary's
God-given role in the history of
salvation.
Now, there's no doubt that she had a
role. She was the Mother of Jesus.
But does that give her any role in terms
of the plan of salvation, how it was to
unfold? No. No.
That only God could do.
And therefore, Jesus, the Word, became
flesh in order to perform that
which humanity couldn't do for itself.
Nor Mary. Nor Mary.
Mary's immaculate conception.
Pope John Paul the Second's starting
point in his treatment of Mary's part in
the great plan of salvation
is the mystery of her immaculate
conception.
I just read that portion to show that
he's bound Mhm. By the to the dogma
dogma of papal infallibility. Yes.
Okay.
Even further, in fact, at the eternal
divine thought and love in which Mary
was conceived before, infinitely before,
her conception on earth.
So, in the mind of God, she was already
being prepared immaculately for him.
And then then he quotes the Angelus
address where the Pope said these
things.
And in a striking meditation on the
meaning of Advent, the Pope returns to
this idea of the eternal origins of Mary
in the mind and heart of God.
And then lower down it says it takes
place in the time between the fall of
the first man and the coming of the
redeemer.
The Pope then refers to God's promise to
our first parents after the fall.
I will put enmity between you and the
woman
and between your seed and her seed.
He shall bruise your head and you shall
bruise his heel. Now Martin, it's
interesting to me that he quotes the
verse correctly.
But the Douay Bible, which is the Jesuit
version,
says she shall crush your head.
But remember this is a post-Vatican II
Pope.
So he tweaks it and he puts the correct
version in there so as not to alienate
the Protestants. You see we must see how
these post-Vatican Popes think.
Always bearing in mind that we're
talking about Pope Francis, Right. Yes.
So what he says on the plane
to someone that
Martin Luther was not wrong when it came
to justification.
That's not according to the Council of
Trent.
And it wasn't ex cathedra, it wasn't
infallible. It was just a comment, it
means nothing.
Right?
That's how it is. Can you see? We need
to make this quite clear.
So if we continue, it says
Christ is always the son of the woman.
God's choice of Christ extends
ultimately to all his brothers and
sisters, but first to Mary.
So he's making a point for giving Mary a
special elevated position.
He writes here, "In bestowing on Mary
the privilege of the Immaculate
Conception,
the eternal Father had in mind the
dignity of his incarnate son
whose human origins he could not permit
to be affected by the least taint of
sin."
Now Martin, that is astounding.
So where did he get his unique
sinlessness from? According to this.
From his mother. From his mother.
Uh not from his father.
This sounds a lot like the pagan
mythology.
It is in fact pagan mythology. It's
exactly the same. It's like um Semiramis
and Osiris. Correct. She was also
immaculately impregnated and gave rise
to this immaculate one. So this is pagan
philosophy at its
I won't don't want to say best, I want
to say at its worst.
Okay.
So
when it comes to Mary's faith,
a little chapter, this is the key to her
destiny.
The teaching is recalled by the Pope who
quotes the statements of the Second
Vatican Council
that the Virgin Mary at the message of
the angel received the word of God in
her heart and in her body.
So can you see that the Second Vatican
Council is being used to smooth the way
without getting rid of the dogmas.
Exactly. Without admitting to a mistake.
Yes, but because still
points out that
it was infallible
previously. Correct.
And then there is this prayer of the
Pope. This is the prayer to the Virgin
al tertium
in 1980.
Let us listen to the Pope as he
expresses these eternal doctrines about
Mary, quote,
"With the whole church, I profess and
proclaim that Jesus Christ is the only
mediator between God and man,
for his incarnation brought to Adam's
sons who are subjected to the power of
sin and death redemption and
justification.
At the same time, I'm deeply convinced
that no one has been called to
participate so deeply as you,
the mother of the redeemer, in this
immense and extraordinary mystery."
And then he continues with the chapter
"Mary is the spiritual mother of
mankind."
She is the spiritual mother of mankind.
Now this becomes very interesting.
So the mystery of the redemption took
shape, the Pope declares, quote,
"beneath the heart of the Virgin of
Nazareth
when she proclaimed her fiat"
in inverted commas.
Now we must understand this word fiat.
It's very important
because Pope Francis drove in a little
Fiat
when he came to the United States and
everybody referred to his humility.
In actual fact, it was a statement of
arrogance.
Because the word fiat means formal
authorization.
It's a decree.
So if you have a fiat decree, it cannot
be moved. It's a law of Medes and
Persians. infallible. It's the paws of
the bear, right?
So this is all very interesting. So
there are certain things there which are
fiat, which are decrees.
We read a little further, it says they
understand the words spoken from the
cross as addressed to each of them.
Spiritual motherhood knows no limits. So
when Jesus said, "Behold your mother,"
he was not speaking to John the disciple
alone. He was speaking to all of
humanity.
So she became the mother of humanity
there.
The Bible knows nothing of this.
Eve was the mother of humanity. But Eve
wasn't the spiritual mother of humanity
either. No.
No. Nobody is the spiritual mother of of
anybody.
No, you can have examples of of fine
spirituality and Mary was one of them.
We're not running down Mary. We're
running down papal encyclicals which are
contrary to scripture.
So three moments are highlighted in this
account of the spiritual motherhood of
Mary, the moment when she conceived the
son of Nazareth,
the words of Jesus to Mary and John at
Calvary, and the coming of the Holy
Spirit at Pentecost. Now it gets
interesting.
In response to the prayers of Mary and
the disciples,
Mary becomes first the mother of Jesus
physically, but also spiritually.
That is by welcoming into her heart in
faith.
At the foot of the cross,
she becomes the spiritual mother of all
men
represented there by Saint John. And at
Pentecost, she becomes specifically
mother of the church,
which at that moment is fully born and
sent into the world in the power of the
Holy Spirit. Now Martin,
it's fascinating to me how they expand
on this topic.
Because at one stage there was an
article in a German magazine
where it stated that John Paul the
Second
was not averse to the idea of Mary being
somehow part of the Trinity.
And then there is this idea that the
Holy Spirit is feminine
and maybe she's associated with that
role.
Now they didn't go that far, but in any
case,
this this issue with the Holy Spirit. So
if we read further, and just as Mary,
the praying Virgin of Nazareth, the
Virgin of faith
and trust in God has been the active
instrument of the Holy Spirit in the
incarnation
of the divine redeemer,
so now in the cenacle, the Holy Spirit
uses her prayer,
her holy receptive faith to bring the
church finally into being. Thus Mary
continues the maternal role she had
begun at the moment of the incarnation.
So Martin,
who is the medium through whom the Holy
Spirit now works? Mary. Mary. So and her
if her prayers are used, then that part
of the sanctuary where the incense goes
up and that prayers is not Jesus's
anymore, now it's Mary's. It's Mary. Now
we'll get into that a little bit later
because we discussed in the previous
one,
and this gets rather complicated,
that the charismatic movement,
which is based on the Holy Spirit,
is thus, according to this philosophy, a
movement
of Mary. Correct.
Now
in a sense, Mary
is the negation
of what God has said.
Because God said
the wages of sin is death.
And all have sinned and fall short of
the glory of God.
There's no one righteous, no, not
one.
Mary was born under the law. In other
words, under the condemnation of the
law. She is as much in need of
redemption as anyone else.
Yes.
We see that the papers he has negated
all of them and made her the medium
of the Holy Spirit. Now, question.
When the Bible says that the end-time
Babylon will be a hold of every foul and
detestable bird.
A bird is a symbol of the Holy Spirit
when it is a clean bird, the dove.
So, an unclean bird is an unclean
spirit.
Isn't this the manifestation of the
devil?
Now, interesting.
Yes.
Because that's like you said, we will be
discussed this, but this pertains to
Protestants.
Yes.
Now, when he talks about Mary at the
foot of the cross, it says, "It is worth
noting that the Pope
in this as in his Marian teaching,
faithfully following Vatican II,
avoids completely the use of the term
co-redemptrix."
It says so in this book.
So, that's why that he's avoiding it,
but the thought is there.
He's He's invoking it.
He is. And implying it,
but not using the word.
Isn't that interesting? Mhm.
So, he didn't go and sit on his papal
chair and declare it infallibly because
that would have damaged the ecumenical
movement, but in his teaching, he's
teaching it.
Okay, very interesting.
He's careful to keep clear of any
terminology
that might in the least be open to the
inference that Mary contributed anything
to the work of redemption that did not
already depend on Christ's saving
sacrifice.
So, they are sneakily circumventing it.
So, let's look at this chapter on the
mother of the church.
He recalls the teaching of the Second
Vatican Council on Mary's spiritual
motherhood and speaks of the church's
great debt to the council
for the manner in which it placed this
teaching in a new and clearer light. Can
you see how important these councils
were? Yes.
The Pope also, on more than one
occasion, recalls the solemn invocation
of Mary by Pope Paul VI
under the title Mother of the Church.
So, now she's the mother of the church,
she's the mother of everyone.
Now, if she's the mother of everyone,
then everyone belongs to the church.
That means all the separated children
must come together, and that's exactly
what Pope
Benedict said. Isn't
It all comes together.
isn't it interesting thing that you get
this terminology in Revelation?
Correct.
The mother of harlots. The mother of
harlots. And that's the mother of fallen
churches.
Correct.
So, if we continue, Pope John Paul II in
fact asks everything from Mary.
There's no genuine need of the church or
of mankind that lies outside of her
interest.
Mary, he declares, "is always at the
very center of our prayers. She is the
first amongst those who ask. She is
omnipotentia
supplex."
The omnipotence of intercession.
Martin.
She's the omnipotence of intercession.
Hasn't he just thereby negated what he
said previously?
All right, he continues to describe
that.
He says, "To describe Mary in these
terms may appear exaggerated at first
sight.
What must be noted, however, is that the
sphere of Mary's omnipotence in inverted
commas
is precisely that of intercession.
She is
the unfailing
efficacy with her divine son of her
mother's prayer.
So, basically, she's the she's the
co-redeemer and she is a co-advocate.
These are all titles that have been
suggested
that she is advocate for the people of
God, which again robs Jesus of his
position.
Yes.
Then he talks about the genius of the
mother.
I remember that Mother Teresa said, "No
Mary, no Jesus."
Yeah. Yeah. That's fascinating. That
sums it up completely, right?
In actual fact, I always wanted to
remind Mother Teresa
that it should be turned round. Without
Jesus, no Mary.
Because he created her in the first
place, right?
Okay.
So, the Second Vatican Council that Mary
occupies a place in the church which is
the highest after Christ and also
closest to us, and he quotes Lumen
Gentium,
page 53.
This does not mean, it should be
stressed, that we must think of Christ
as remote
in contrast to Mary who is near.
Mary is herself part of the mystery of
Christ and his redemption.
In her, Christ is present as the son of
the woman.
There is no Christ separated from her.
Now,
this becomes a dogma which is absolutely
amazing.
Now, Martin,
if you had to take yourself
and you would have to promulgate a
doctrine like this in relation to your
mother,
whether you were now a good man or an
evil man,
just hypothetically,
is your mother
intimately involved in every
good or evil decision that you make in
your life? No. No, she may have laid the
groundwork in your upbringing, but but
she is not the one that actually
performs Yeah, and makes the decision.
But here, it seems as if Jesus He
couldn't choose anything if it weren't
for his mother. Correct.
That's why.
In many Roman Catholic circles, they
come to the conclusion that nobody comes
to the Father except through Jesus,
but nobody comes to Jesus except through
Mary.
Now, you have a problem
because you have another mediator
between the two, and there are
literally hundreds
of papal statements and Catholic father
statements which elevate Mary to that
position.
And none of what I'm reading here
negates it in any shape or form.
Repeatedly, the Pope affirms that the
genius of the mother is the genius of
the heart. A mother, he says, is a heart
personified, and this genius is
expressed in love. That is why Mary as
mother is called to lead everyone to the
redeemer,
to bear witness to him even without
words, only with love,
in which the genius of the heart is
expressed. Everyone is led
to God through Mary.
Is that scriptural, Martin? No, not at
all.
So, we are reading here
about post-Vatican II thinking of Mary.
And the Protestant world is saying that
the Roman Catholic Church has changed.
Yeah.
Here's another plan of
redemption.
This one to me, this little chapter to
me is fascinating. We don't have to go
through it all,
but let's just
look at this one still.
She's the ideal image of the church.
As well as being mother of the church,
Mary is its type
or archetype, the ideal image, its ideal
image.
This has been highlighted by the Second
Vatican Council.
Can you see where the council comes in
all the time? Exactly.
Not negating anything, highlighting it,
actually. Right.
It is also the teaching of Pope John
Paul II. Just as every mother, he
remarks, transmits her own resemblance
to her children, so there is a deep
resemblance between Mary and the church.
A little further, he says, "Mary is
therefore the first fruit and the most
perfect image of the church." Martin,
whose image are we created in?
God.
Whose image should we reflect? Jesus.
Who are they reflecting? Mary. Mary.
So, the level that you have to reach
goes no higher than man. Yeah, correct.
He's opted for man,
man in his entirety.
And by using and invoking Mary in this
fashion,
man becomes his own redeemer.
And the blood of the lamb
is negated. This is a very serious
doctrine.
She is the archetype or prototype of the
glorified church in the future.
Martin,
this takes away the position of Christ.
This negates it. If Protestants would
read this,
they would understand why the world is
heading where it is heading.
Now, listen to this statement over here.
In fact, the Pope affirms both Mary and
the church are rightly said to beget
and fashion Christ here on earth.
Can I read that again? Yeah.
In fact, the Pope affirms both Mary and
the church are rightly said to beget and
fashion Christ here on earth.
Mary gave the Lord to the world,
realizing the type of the church in
herself for the first time.
And the church in her turn, following
Mary, continues to manifest him to the
world, to mold him in the hearts of men.
Martin, this is a very serious issue. I
don't think
elevate her so high.
They It's almost as if Jesus is a little
bit less. Absolutely. Without him, we
can do nothing.
Let's jump to the final chapter because
I've really had quite enough of this by
now.
It says Mary, the mother of unity. Mhm.
Okay.
Uh the Lord Jesus says come out and be
separate, right?
It may be felt that the very
comprehensive role assigned by the Pope
to Mary in the history of salvation
and in the life and mission of the
church may create difficulties in the
path to Christian unity.
For large numbers of our fellow
Christians.
And it should. Yes.
There is no doubt a challenge here for
ecumenism. Mhm. They realize it. They're
putting it in writing.
They're not even sugarcoating or hiding
this. No. No.
Take it or leave it.
Protestant brethren,
shape up or ship out, right?
Yeah.
This is amazing.
Then it says here,
who must devote more attention to the
role of Mary than for one reason or
another it has hitherto received.
Certainly,
the strongly biblical quality of the
Pope's Marian doctrine and devotion and
his emphasis on Mary's total dependence
on Christ should make it easier for
Christians of the Reformation tradition
to meet him on the common ground.
So, he quoted a Bible verse correctly,
then
and then violated its principles
and says, "But you know what?
He did say to John, 'Behold your
mother.' What's your problem?"
Huh? Yeah.
As far as the Pope himself is concerned,
there is no doubt that whatever
difficulties for ecumenism he may
perceive in the church's Marian
doctrine,
at least in the short term, these could
not, in his view, justify any minimizing
of Mary's role as made known in
scripture and as understood by the
tradition of the church. Let's leave it
at that.
Yeah.
We have not changed. Our doctrines are
infallible. We will not move in our
position on Mary. We will sugarcoat it
so that
you may come on board,
but accept it or face the consequences.
That's what they said. That's what
they're saying.
So, having said that, let's move on.
There were some issues with
our quoting Thomas Aquinas.
And
I said at one stage that
he was quoted in many papal encyclicals,
including Rerum Novarum.
And being in these encyclicals
and being part of this process
that came post Vatican II. Of course,
Thomas Aquinas lived way back. We
remember that Thomas Aquinas was quoted
in papal encyclicals such as Rerum
Novarum.
And
we have to see where this actually leads
to because this is important. Yes. We've
got some examples of It's It's
materializing in our day. Correct. So,
let's look at this statement again.
He wrote, "Because the goods of some are
due to others by natural law, there is
no sin if the poor take the goods of
their neighbors."
Now, we must still get to this issue of
natural law. I think we'll discuss that
in the next one.
So, Thomas wrote, "In cases of need, all
things are common property, so that
there would seem to be no sin in taking
another's property for need has made it
common."
So, Martin,
if you want to implement Catholic social
teaching
where everybody becomes equal,
where, as Klaus Schwab says, you possess
nothing and are happy,
and you receive a social grant from the
government on a monthly basis, so that
everybody is equal,
then need should not become a factor,
right?
Yes, correct. But seeing that need is a
factor today,
we have to demonstrate to the world
what the consequences of the divide
between rich and poor really are. We
need to level these playing fields.
Isn't that the doctrine of social
teaching? Yes.
Let's just look where this leads to.
Here we have a video clip of what's
happening in society today.
And there were some discussions as well
on the various news outlets of the
world. So, let's just look at this one.
Call 911.
Wow.
17 Walgreens councilmen pulling out of
the Bay Area because they can't make any
money because you you can walk in and
steal whatever you want and it's no
longer a crime. So, Walgreens is like,
"We're out." Prosecutors in San
Francisco and in many other places
throughout the state of California, for
example, but not just there, no longer
charge shoplifters.
So, people steal whatever they want. The
store is closing due to what local
reports are calling a spree of rampant
shoplifting.
And look at this. Just 15 minutes after
an Inside Edition crew showed up at the
drugstore, we found this guy jumping
over the front counter, taking an air
bed, and leaving the store on his
scooter. No questions asked. No one
stopping him. Put him on the ground.
Yeah, get up.
Hey.
Let's go.
Go in. Go in. Let's go.
Stealing at the back of the store.
He just came in with a suitcase. That's
crazy, dog. Every day. They just come in
with suitcases? Yeah.
You know that just made me agitated, all
right?
I don't care.
All right.
Call 911.
They're all in cuffs right now. They're
all in cuffs right now. No!
You got everything BUT A STOP.
YOU GOT A STOP.
THIS AMERICAN PUT A STOP. WASN'T HE
GOING TO BEAT YOU? WHAT THE Y'ALL
DOING?
What are you doing?
I just got off work.
What the you want? You want me to
call myself a cop? So, WHAT'S UP,
HURT HIM.
I'M GOING TO ASK YOU WHAT THE YOU
DOING. YOU DON'T HAVE TO HURT HIM.
WHAT'S UP, MAN?
PLEASE GET OUT OF HERE.
OH MY GOD. I GOT THAT, BRO. BRO, DON'T
HEY!
WATCH YOUR BACK.
COME ON, BUDDY.
COME ON.
TO BE CLEAR, IT'S NOT THAT AMERICANS
have become more prone to steal.
It's that stealing is now allowed. And
when you allow something, you get more
of it.
Martin,
let's just look at this in a little bit
more detail.
We know what the social teaching of the
Roman Catholic Church is. Mhm.
And we know what the learned doctors
have contributed
in terms of this doctrine, right?
Thomas Aquinas.
Now,
this This a very clever way
of bringing about that system which they
ultimately want.
This is a Hegelian dialectic.
You first allow the divide between rich
and poor to become ridiculous.
Mhm. So that someone like Bill Gates or
any one of these
possess billions
and the others possess nothing.
And then you allow the social tensions
to take place.
And this is not a racial issue. This
covers the economic field irrespective
of what race you are part of.
And then you have this tremendous
tension.
And then eventually you get to the point
where need has made all things common.
Mhm.
And you allow stealing and that upsets
people, right?
Correct. And some people get very upset,
especially when it happens in the
privacy of your own home.
Or perhaps at the point of a gun. Yeah.
And uh
what is the solution to this?
Let's stop this great divide
and equalize it.
Mhm.
Then we will have removed this problem.
So you create the problem.
Yes. And then you produce the solution
for the problem.
And then you have complete control
Correct. over every single aspect. And
this is where Roman Catholicism is
leading the world by the nose.
Yes.
Because people are so involved in this
crisis because everybody is touched by
it.
It seems that the only way out is to
follow their way.
Correct.
So Martin, if we want to address all of
these issues
then uh we need a time of trouble,
right? Yeah.
And the Bible says
and it's interesting that the the
heading topic in the King James says the
time of the end.
Yeah.
Daniel 12:1 and at that time shall
Michael stand up the great prince
which standeth for the children of thy
people and we've discussed this verse
before. Mhm.
When he stands up, that's the close of
probation.
And there shall be a time of trouble
such as never was since there was a
nation even to that same time.
And at that time
thy people shall be delivered, everyone
that shall be found written in the book.
So Martin
if you want crime to increase
then defund the police.
Correct. And let us get this period of
turmoil
so that we can introduce the legislation
that we want. And before we do that,
let's just put some controls in place
that we can control exactly who is
allowed to buy
and sell.
Yes. And also important to remember
what we've shown
where does it come from?
It comes from Rome. Comes from Rome. So
everything that you see that's happening
in the world
is the beast system running.
Correct. And there are so many people
that want to
put the blame on someone else.
Exactly. It's either a racial problem or
it's a Zionist problem or it is a this
Democrat or Republican problem. Or a
political problem. It's not. It's a
Roman problem.
Yes.
And if we don't realize this and if we
do not find our source of salvation at
the right source
then we will be swept away in this
current in a time of trouble that says
such as never was.
May God give us the wisdom
to make this book
the standard and not philosophies and
traditions which are based on pagan
philosophies and pagan religions.
Let's pray.
Heavenly Father
help us to understand that we are
dealing with an enemy
that uses the word of God.
When you were tempted, Lord Jesus
there in the wilderness of temptation
the devil came with
the word of God and you countered with
it is written.
Let us also counter
with it is written.
Is my prayer in Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Thank you for watching this
video.
To subscribe click here.
When the bell appears
click again to get notifications.
To watch the next video
click here.
Thank you.